let's begin with the ongoing pandemic
that has cost
our country so much
senator harris the coronavirus is not
under control
over the past week johns hopkins reports
that
39 states have had more coveted cases
over the past seven days
than in the week before nine states have
set new records
even if a vaccine is released soon the
next administration will face
hard choices what would a biden
administration do
in january and february that a trump
administration
wouldn't do would you impose new
lockdowns for businesses in schools and
hot spots
a federal mandate to wear masks you have
two minutes to respond without
interruption
thank you susan well the
american people have witnessed what is
the greatest
failure of any presidential
administration in the history of our
country
and here are the facts two hundred and
ten thousand dead people in our country
in just the last several months over
seven million people who have contracted
this disease
one in five businesses closed
we're looking at frontline workers who
have been treated
like sacrificial workers we are looking
at
over 30 million people
who in the last several months had to
file for unemployment
and here's the thing on january 28th
the vice president and the president
were informed
about the nature of this pandemic they
were informed that it's lethal
in consequence that it is airborne
that it will affect young people and
that
it would be contracted because it is
airborne
and they knew what was happening and
they didn't tell
you can you imagine if you knew on
january 28th
as opposed to march 13th what they knew
what you might have done to prepare
they knew and they covered it up the
president said it was a hoax
they minimized the seriousness of it the
president said
you're on one side of his ledger if you
wear a mask you're on the other side of
his ledger
if you don't and in spite of all of that
today they still don't have a plan
they still don't have a plan well joe
biden does and our plan
is about what we need to do around a
national strategy
for contact tracing for testing for
administration of
the vaccine and making sure that it will
be free for all
that is the plan that joe biden has and
that i have
knowing that we have to get a hold of
what has been going on
and we need to save our country and joe
biden is the best leader to do that and
frankly this administration has
forfeited
thank you their right to re-election
based on this thank you senator harris
vice president pence more than 210 000
americans have died of covet 19
since february the u.s death toll as a
percentage of our population
is higher than that of almost every
other wealthy nation
on earth for instance our death rate is
two and a half times that of canada next
door
you head the administration's
coronavirus task force
why is the u.s death toll as a
percentage of our population
higher than that of almost every other
wealthy country
and you have two minutes to respond
without interruption susan thank you
and i want to thank the commission and
the university of utah for
hosting this event and uh senator harris
it's privileged to be on the stage with
you
and our nation has gone through a very
challenging time this year
but i want the american people to know
that from the very first
day president donald trump has put the
health of america first
before there were more than five cases
in the united states
all people who had returned from china
president donald trump did what no other
american president
had ever done and that was he suspended
all
travel from china the second largest
economy in the world
now senator joe biden biden opposed
that decision he said it was xenophobic
and hysterical but i can tell you having
led the white house coronavirus task
force that that decision alone by
president trump
bought us invaluable time to stand up
the greatest national mobilization
since world war ii and i believe it
saved hundreds of
thousands of american lives because with
that time we were able to reinvent
testing more than 115 million tests had
been done to date
we were able to see to the delivery of
billions of supplies so our doctors
and nurses had the resources support
they needed and we began
really before the month of february was
art to develop a vaccine
and to develop medicines and
therapeutics had been saving lives all
along the way
and under president trump's leadership
operation warp speed we believe we'll
have
literally tens of millions of doses of a
vaccine before the end of this year
the reality is when you look at the
biden plan it reads an awful lot
like what president trump and i and our
task force have been doing every step
of the way and quite frankly
when i look at their plan that talks
about advancing testing
creating new ppe developing a vaccine
it looks a little bit like plagiarism
which is something joe biden knows a
little bit about
and i think the american people know
that this is a president who has put the
health of america first and the american
people i believe with my heart
can be proud of the sacrifices they have
made
it's saved thank you american lives
senator harris
would you like to respond absolutely
whatever the vice president is claiming
the administration has done
clearly it hasn't worked when you're
looking at over two hundred and ten
thousand dead bodies in our country
american lives that have been lost
families that are grieving
that loss and you know the
vice president is the head of the task
force
and knew on january 28th how serious
this was and then
thanks to bob woodward we learned
that they knew about it and then when
that was exposed
the vice president said when asked well
why didn't you all tell anybody
he said because the president wanted
people to remain
calm well let's go no but susan i this
is important
and i want to add if mr vice president
i'm speaking i have i'm speaking
yeah you can have 15 more seconds and
then we'll give the vice president a
chance
so i want to ask the american people how
calm were you when you were panicked
about where you're going to get your
next roll of toilet paper
how come were you when your kids were
sent home from school and you didn't
know when they could go back
how kind thank you thank you when your
children couldn't see your parents
because you were afraid they could kill
them let's give vice president pence a
chance to respond vice presidents you
have one minute to receive you know
there's not a day gone by that i haven't
thought of every american family that's
lost a loved one
and i want all of you to know that
you'll always be in our hearts
and in our prayers but when you say what
the american people have done
over these last eight months hasn't
worked that's a great disservice
to the sacrifices the american people
have made
the reality if i may if i may finish
that
the reality is dr fauci said everything
that he told the president in the oval
office the president told the american
people
now president trump i will tell you has
boundless confidence in the american
people and he always spoke with
confidence that we'd get through this
together
but when you say it hasn't worked when
dr fauci and dr burks and our medical
experts came to us in the second week of
march
they said if the president didn't take
the unprecedented step
of shutting down roughly half of the
american economy
that we could lose 2.2 million
americans and that's the reality thank
you they also said truth if we did
everything right susan we could still
lose more than 200 000 americans
vice president one life lost is too many
susan
but the american people i believe
deserve credit
for the sacrifices that they have made
putting the health of their family
and their neighbors first our doctors
our nurses our first thank you vice
president pence and i'm going to speak
up on behalf of what the american people
have done vice president pence you were
in the front row
in a rose garden event 11 days ago what
seems to have been a super spreader
event for senior administration and
congressional officials
no social distancing few masks and now a
cluster of coronavirus cases among those
who were there
how can you expect americans to follow
the administration's safety guidelines
to protect themselves from covid
when you at the white house have not
been doing so
well the american people have
demonstrated
over the last eight months that when
given the facts
they're willing to put the health of
their families and their neighbors and
people they don't even know
first president trump and i have great
confidence in
in the american people and and their
ability
to take that information and put it into
practice
in the height of the epidemic when we
were losing
a heartbreaking number of 2 500
americans a day
we surged resources to new jersey and
new york and new orleans and detroit we
told the american people what needed to
be done and the american people made the
sacrifices
when the outbreak in the sun belt
happened this summer again americans
stepped forward
but the reality is the work of the
president of the united states goes on
a vacancy on the supreme court of the
united states
uh has come upon us and the president
introduced judge amy coney barry thank
you
thank you very much if i may say that
rose garden event
there's been a great deal of speculation
about it my wife karen and i were there
and honored to be there
many of the people who were at that
event susan actually were tested for
coronavirus and it was an outdoor event
which
all of our scientists regularly and
routinely advise
the difference here is president trump
and i trust the american people
to make choices in the best interest of
their health
joe biden and kamala harris consistently
talk about
mandates and not not just mandates with
the coronavirus but
a government takeover of healthcare
thank you thank you green new deal
all government control we're about
freedom and respecting the freedom of
the american people
let's talk about respecting the american
people you respect the american people
when you tell them the truth
you respect the american people when you
have the courage to be a leader
speaking of those things that you may
not want people to hear but they need to
hear so they can protect themselves
but this administration stood on
information that if you had as a parent
if you had as a worker knowing you
didn't have enough money saved up
and now you're standing in a food line
because of the ineptitude of an
administration that was unwilling to
speak the truth to the american people
so let's talk about caring about the
american people the american people have
had to sacrifice far too much
because of the incompetence of this
administration it is asking too much of
the people who
are talking about that asking too much
of the people
that they would not be equipped with the
information they need
to help themselves to protect their
parents president i'm sorry
kelly harris senator harris i mean i'm
sorry that's fine i'm comma no no you're
senator harris to me
um for life to get back to normal dr
anthony fauci and other experts say
that most of the people who can be
vaccinated need to be vaccinated
but half of americans now say they
wouldn't take a vaccine if it was
released now
if the trump administration approves a
vaccine before or after the election
should americans take it and would you
take it
if the public health professionals if dr
fauci if the doctors tell us that we
should take it i'll be the first in line
to take it
absolutely but if donald trump tells us
i should that we should take it i'm not
taking it